hey guys at seven I have a quick
question for you I want to know if you
think nice people finish first or last
in business this came out because I've
been working with a media coach and
she's been training me on making these
videos on answering calls on the radio
and you know being more on point when
I'm in front of the camera doing
anything related to the media today she
told me you have to be tougher you have
to show entrepreneurs more tough love
especially when I'm on the radio a
problem my face is people call in and I
only have a few minutes to help them and
people are talking too much she wants me
to interrupt them yell at them if I have
to get their attention you know call
them crazy whatever it takes to get them
to listen to what I have to say she
wants me to be meaner and I want to know
what you guys think this is a big
stretch for me this is outside my
comfort zone in general I'm a pretty
nice guy easy to get along with I avoid
conflict if I can I'm not afraid of it
if I have to get into it if it's
important but in general i'm not erect
going around picking fights with people
our opinion is that through tough love
i'm going to be able to help them more
and i like to hear what you guys have to
think do nice people finish first or
last in business please leave a comment
below have your vote and we'll see where
it goes thank you guys i'm looking
forward to the comments see you soon